Holiday excess
might be inevitable,
but it doesn't have
to be bad for you.
Here's how.
Hey this is Annie Gaus
guest hosting for D News.
One of the best things
about the holiday season
is the excuse to sit around
and eat tons of good food,
drink tons of nog,
and just do nothing,
which is part of the reason
why it's so common to pack
on a couple pounds
during the holidays.
According to a 2000
study by the New England
Journal of Medicine,
people can gain an average
of just over a pound
over the fall and winter.
And not surprisingly,
even short term periods
of overeating and inactivity
can have negative effects
on your blood sugar
and metabolism.
But don't worry,
there is good news.
A new study shows that
exercise can counteract
those negative
effects, even if you
are gaining a little
bit of weight.
Physiologists from
the University of Bath
tested groups of
young men, having
them consume more
calories than normal,
the equivalent of
quality overeating.
One was sedentary.
The other exercised on a
treadmill for 45 minutes a day.
And in just over a
week, the inactive group
saw a whole range
of negative effects,
like a decrease in
blood sugar control
and changing gene
expression in fat cells
linked to poor metabolism.
But the exercising group showed
normal blood sugar levels
and less undesirable
gene activity.
But what's interesting
is that they
matched the excess
calories according
to your level of activity.
They had the active
group consume even more.
So everyone was at a
similar level of excess.
So the implication
of the study is
that even if you're stuffing
your face with ham and fruit
cake during the Christmas
week, exercise doesn't just
burn off some of those calories.
It can also have a
protective effect
against some of the bad things
that can happen in your body.
So in summary, eat,
drink, be merry,
don't forget to move
sometimes, and more importantly
have fun over the holidays.
As always, you get in
touch with the show
at Twitter and
Facebook at D News.
And you can also find me
on Twitter at AnnieGaus.
Thanks for watching,
and see you next time.